c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir une date celle de février
2024 c'est l'échéance présidentielle
fixée par bamako le gouvernement malien
a adopté un calendrier électoral de
transition à trois jours du sommet de la
cedeao un sommet qui doit se pencher sur
les sanctions sévères prises en janvier
contre les militaires au pouvoir dans le
pays décryptage dans ce journal et ce
soir nous évoquons également la
transition en guinée neuf mois après le
coup d'état avec notre invité l'ancien
premier ministre guinéen kabiné komara a
calé son regard sur la situation dans
son pays mais aussi dans la région
entretien à suivre
journée historique à kinshasa l'ancien
premier ministre patrice lumumba est élu
mais plus de 61 ans après sa mort ce une
cérémonie émouvante qui s'est tenu
symboliquement le jour anniversaire de
l'indépendance elle marque la fin de dix
jours de commémoration en belgique et à
travers toute la république démocratique
du congo nous serons à kinshasa la fin
de cette édition
février 2024 pour la présidentielle et
octobre 2023 pour les élections
législatives le gouvernement malien a
adopté un calendrier électoral de
transition une annonce qui intervient à
trois jours d'un sommet crucial de la
cedeao à accra au ghana l'organisation
ouest africaine doit se pencher sur les
sanctions sévères prises en janvier
dernier pour sanctionner le pouvoir
malien julien bretons
les électeurs maliens savent enfin quand
ils pourront retourner aux urnes le
gouvernement de transition dirigé par la
junte militaire depuis août 2000 20 a
annoncé vendredi les dates des prochains
scrutins en direct à la télévision
publique les élections législatives
premier tour le dimanche 29 octobre 2023
pour l'élection du président de la
république le premier tour le dimanche 4
fév et 2024 la version détaillée des
différents chronogramme
selon publié vulgarisé expliqué à
l'endroit de notre opinion nationale et
de l'opinion internationale
un calendrier électoral annoncé trois
jours seulement avant un sommet de la
communauté économique des états
d'afrique de l'ouest
l'organisation doit se pencher à nouveau
sur les sanctions prises contre la junte
sur laquelle elle fait pression pour un
retour des civils au pouvoir
des sanctions qui pèsent très lourd sur
une économie malienne déjà éprouvée en
janvier dernier les chefs d'état de la
cedeao avait notamment décidé de fermer
leur frontière avec le mali et de
suspendre toute transaction commerciale
dans la tente d'un calendrier électoral
acceptable à leurs yeux ces nouvelles
dates doivent être soumises à
l'approbation des chefs d'état de la
cedeao lors de leur prochain sommet à
accra au ghana le 3 juillet prochain
et puis sachez pour être complet que le
mali est opposé à une enquête de l'onu
sur des violations présumées des droits
humains le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
s'est prononcé en faveur du prolongement
pour 12 mois de sa mission de maintien
de la paix au mali en place depuis neuf
ans
la transition on en parle aussi beaucoup
en guinée neuf mois après le coup d'état
qui a conduit au départ du président
alpha condé les principaux partis
politiques et la société civile sont
très inquiet pour en parler l'ancien
premier ministre guinéen kabiné komara
est notre invité ce soir bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous bonsoir madame
alors je ne peux pas commencer cette
interview sans vous faire réagir sur sur
le mali
pensez vous que cette nouvelle échéance
fixée par bamako est raisonnable
va-t-elle rassurer la cedeao qui tient
son sommet dans trois jours budaj
quoique le cas malien atypique c'est un
pays qui veut le savoir dans ce tout mal
depuis un certain temps depuis des
élections législatives extrêmement
contestée du temps du président et des
cas auxquels heures n'a pas su réagir à
temps qui ont conduit à beaucoup de
contestations un peu utilitaire deuxième
et les sanctions prises par la cedeao
contre le mali ne font pas mal seulement
qu'au mali mais ça fait mal aussi appris
à ses dépens qu'il est temps il est
vraiment temps que les paiements glacé
d'heure et le mali
regarde cette fois ci la deuxième
proposition pour que je puisse sortir
c'est un exemple dans laquelle un pays
difficile 7000 climatique des frontières
pour le set est à 2000 qu un milliard
quatre cent mille quatre cent mille
kilomètres carrés six fois le sénégal
la moitié des revenus du sénégal trois
fois la france devant la france ou ex
tempo qui n'a pas beaucoup de moyens
mais qui doit faire face à de grands
problèmes sécuritaires il est essentiel
que s'il s'appelle en compte avec
l'ensemble les facteurs que l'on connaît
maintenant donc les sanctions puisque le
fait que le mali puisse retrouver
vraiment nouvelle et ça et vous avez de
l'espoir que ce que cette échéance fixée
par bamako rassure la cedeao vous pensez
que ça ça pourrait fonctionner ce que je
sais c'est que la cel met à la recherche
d'une solution de sortie de crise
je ne vois pas pourquoi il ne l'a pas
une certaine mansuétude pour que cette
fois ci venant soit le point de départ
parce que le mal est aussi ont fait
beaucoup d'efforts alors la gestion de
la transition dans votre pays la guinée
est très contesté par les principaux
partis politiques et la société civile
ils menacent d'ailleurs de descendre
dans la rue partagez vous leur
inquiétude que pensez vous de cette
gestion de la transition en tant
qu'ancien premier ministre
je dois déjà déjà moi même eu l'occasion
déjà une première transition en 2009
donc la télévision ne sont pas faciles
même quand vous le placez dans le
contrat global en afrique de l'ouest la
guinée vient après maintenant de coup
d'état il y en a eu 96 sur tout le
continent depuis les indépendances 50 en
afrique de l'ouest
c'est vraiment trop c'est évident
qu'elle s'était même un mois mais les
causes de coups d'état sont connus c'est
la mauvaise gouvernance c'est le faire
qu'il ya des élections préfecture qui
est le fait que la gestion publique
autocratique donc ce samedi à deux coups
d'état et ceux qui arrivent au pouvoir
disent qu'il doit faire la rédemption
qui doit faire en sorte que le pays soit
remis sur les trains ceux qui sont dans
la lutte politique et pour cet enfant se
disent que c'est l'occasion pour eux
maintenant d'accès la chaise brax et de
voir comment concilier ces deux
positions à savoir ce que le faire robin
de loin d'eux ceux qui veulent
absolument voir si rapidement je crois
que là les guinéens gelé dans un truc
que j'ai publié à quelques jeux il est
essentiel que les guinéens aient raison
garder la communauté est fatigués de
nous et c'est tellement désespérée de
nom il faut que nous ayons ce nouveau
départ que soit le dernier pour qu'il
n'y ait pas une autre transition
le pays au dessus de tout pour vous
cette gestion enfin que l'ailé les
partis principaux partis politiques et
la société civile doivent patienter
c'est ça lorsque je veux dire ça que
j'étais déjà assez satisfait qu'il ya
quelques jours tout le monde ait répondu
à l'appel du premier ministre ensuite
les uns les autres posent beaucoup de
conditions mais je rappelle à chacun
parce que cette phrase d'un bâtiment il
y avoit de vérité il ya ma vérité et à
la vérité qui est entre nous deux donc
il faut faire preuve de flexibilité pour
arriver à une entente vous pensez que
que vous que pensez-vous du dialogue
entamé justement par par le premier
musée la transition alors je crois que
comme vous le savez c'est rare qu'un
dialogue démarre entièrement sur une
entente de contenu directement comme si
tout est annulé il ya des accrocs mais
je crois que la bonne foi cette fois ci
doivent prévaloir
il est essentiel chacun doit avoir à
l'idée qu'il faut sauver la guinée
serait la guinée suppose que vous mettez
de côté un peu vos égaux que ce soit le
pouvoir que ce soit les partis
politiques la société civile je crois et
la population indienne on vraiment
besoin qui ne certaine accalmie qui
n'est pas des moins que les
investisseurs 7 et qu'on puisse vraiment
s'entendent pour aller aux élections
alors vous parler d'entente vous avez
également mentionné les raisons qui ont
poussé à ce coup d'état la mauvaise
gouvernance vous avez dit vous avez
soutenu la prise de pouvoir de ces
militaires le 5 septembre dernier et
selon certaines informations vous êtes
un médiateur entre le pouvoir de conakry
et la cedeao qu'en est il aujourd'hui de
votre rôle non je n'ai jamais été à mes
côtés à l'entrée la sédré logo de ce que
j'ai essayé de faire c'est d'abord elle
même qu'elle a fait à un moment donné
vous savez que le protocole additionnel
sur la bonne gouvernance de la cedeao
pour poser ou indiqué qu' il n'y a pas
de changement de gouvernement de ces
constitutions moins de six mois avant
les élections donc s'être botté en
touche en guinée parce que le pr alpha
condé a modifié les choses quelques mois
avant la sirène ne pouvait pas la
sanctionner
ce que j'ai à dire c'est que là c'est de
revoir ces protocoles pour qu'il soit
définitivement indiqué que les
changements s'il est conscient que ce
soit 6 mois 2 - neuf mois va ils ne sont
pas autorisés que les deux mandats
doivent être directs partout fort
heureusement dans l'ensemble des 15 pays
de la cedeao sedrun il n'y a que la
gambie dont la constitution est en
préparation qui n'a pas encore de petits
mais même là je crois qu'ils vont
adopter les deux pays que sont la guinée
le malaise je ne vois pas la rumeur
conscient ne pas prévoir ce que
j'appelle un silo à se remettre en cause
pour que les pays et les populations ne
soient pas étonné que 2 500 tombes
pendant comment les sanctions devraient
être prises contre la gouvernante
délicat certains n'ont pas été prises
alors vous avez dit tout à l'heure vous
aviez déjà mener une transition en 2009
si je me souviens bien certains acteurs
politiques guinéens pensent que vous
êtes le candidat des militaires après la
transition à ce que vous serez candidat
à la prochaine élection présidentielle
en guinée sur un fauteuil ou ce livre
parce que moi je me suis toujours
inscrit dans le sens d'aider mon pays
sans aucun calcul quand je suis arrivé
pour faire la transition en 2009 c'est
très important bienvenue budget ni
salaire j'ai même vendu une des
propriétés pour faire fonctionner la
plus mature l affaire de la taille je
demande est auditée et je dis que je
pourrais retourner encore de ma banque
pour continuer mes fonctions mais je
crains que ça nous a laissé un futur
n'est pas très très peu de démission de
tous je n'ai besoin d'eux et je vais
comme on dit je suis dans la même
posture jeudi je n'accepterai jamais que
je vois mon pays allait à la mort sans
intervenu aussi bien au niveau les
partis politiques de l'opposition
du gouvernement
la sautée civile et tout le monde le
connaît je n'entends rien apporté au
parti est ce que vous comptez quand même
être candidat à ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous vous projetez
vous avez un rôle à jouer dans ce rôle
ces candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
alors chaque fois qu'on me pose cette
question ça me fait sourire parce que je
le bois de pin de touche mais je me dis
que on peut saluer son pays sans être
plaisir de la foule et bien la réponse
est donnée merci beaucoup vous êtes je
le rappelle l'ancien premier ministre de
guinée et kabiné komara merci infiniment
d'être venu sur notre plateau répondre à
la coopération d'addis-abeba saluée par
les nations unies les enquêteurs de
l'onu sur les violations des droits de
l'homme en ethiopie ont été autorisés à
se rendre au pour y négocier un accès
plus large aux pays la commission
denquête a été mise en place en décembre
dernier pour une période d'un an
renouvelable kaminer d'élèves dé en dit
plus
l'inquiétude à l'onu règne face à la
possibilité de massacre des civils en
ethiopie jeudi l'onu a annoncé qu'elle
pourrait envoyer une équipe d'enquêteurs
addis abeba d'ici quelques semaines une
fois sur place il espère pouvoir
négocier un accès plus large au reste du
pays
nous sommes extrêmement alarmé par les
atrocités en cours contre les civils
notamment les événements rapportés dans
la région d'oromia toute propagation de
la violence contre les civils alimenté
par les discours de haine ou
d'incitation à la violence fondées sur
l'ethnie ou le sexe est un indicateur
d'alerté précoce est un précurseur de
nouveaux crimes atroces
la commission voudrait enquêter sur les
violations commises par toutes les
parties depuis que la guerre a éclaté en
novembre 2020 avec les séparatistes
militants du front de libération du
peuple de tigray d'un côté et le
gouvernement du premier ministre habib
ahmed de l'autre une trêve humanitaire
est en place depuis mars dernier mais la
situation semble se dégrader malgré cela
le 18 juin des forces armées ont attaqué
des villages dans la région de tôle est
l'attaqué a duré plusieurs heures et des
centaines de personnes ont été
massacrées des mitrailleuses et des
machettes ont été utilisés pour tuer des
civils d'abord les militants ont
commencé à leur tirer dessus puis ils
ont utilisé des machettes pour achever
ce qu'ils ont été blessée mais pas tuée
sous les coups de feu les témoins
accusent l'armée de libération oromo
cette dernière nie avoir été l'auteur du
massacre et accuse à leur tour des
forces pro gouvernementales
les ministres réclament une enquête
indépendante
plus de 61 ans après sa mort patrice
lumumba été inhumé ce jeudi 30 juin à
kinshasa jour de l'anniversaire de
l'indépendance dans le cercueil une dent
de l'ancien premier ministre congolais
remise par la belgique à ses descendants
le 20 juin dernier il s'agit de l'unique
reste du héros national violemment
assassiné notre correspondant qui aimons
bonnes roues étaient sur place
nous sommes sur la place de l'échangeur
de limete en plein coeur de kinshasa
c'est ici dans ce petit mausolée que
vous voyez derrière moi qui a été inhumé
ce jeudi patrice emery lumumba le
premier premier ministre congolais
la cérémonie a eu lieu en petit comité
en présence de deux chefs d'état le
président félix tshisekedi le président
de la république du congo denis sassou
n'guesso étaient également présents
plusieurs enfants de patrice lumumba
ainsi que plusieurs de ses petits
enfants qui ont suivi tout le parcours
du cercueil depuis la belgique et à
travers le congo dans notre culture la
culture bantou il est très important que
le corps puisse être mis en terre selon
les coutumes qui nous sont propres donc
il ya toute une spiritualité autour de
cette question là et je pense que le
peuple latendresse n'a pu voir que le
peuple nous attendait nous a accueillis
a fait fi des disparités tribal a fait
fi des appartenances politiques pour se
réunir et donc on voit que patrice emery
lumumba et plus que tout plus que jamais
une figure de rassemblement le président
félix tshisekedi s'est exprimé pour la
première fois depuis la restitution de
la dépouille de patrice lumumba par la
belgique il a salué un moment historique
pour le pays et a également déclaré que
le moomba reste est une inspiration pour
les combats futurs navires partent j'ai
parlé congrès on nous c'est un grande
joie et on est là on célèbre ça et ça va
marquer aussi l'histoire même de nos
petits-enfants même nous aussi on ne
savait même pas en lan jamin fille mais
c'est grâce à ça qu'on le vend
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vu que le mumbai
rentrer dans la terre de ses ancêtres
est jamais mieux il ya il ya lieu
complice et concrétiser ses rêves bassil
et intérêts prenez d'abord l'unité
nationale parce que ça l'unité nationale
c'est l'effondrement du congo plus de 61
ans après sa mort le héros de
l'indépendance repose donc enfin sur la
terre de ses ancêtres
mais de nombreuses zones d'ombré
subsistent autour de son assassinat la
belgique a reconnu sa responsabilité
morale au début des années 2000 mais
jusqu'à ce jour aucune condamnation n'a
jamais été prononcé par la justice
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à notre chef d'édition célia
karacena merci à nos correspondants sans
qui ce journal ne pourrait pas se faire
et puis surtout merci à vous de votre
fidélité rester avec nous l'info
continue sur france 24
[Musique]